since Republicans have taken over
control of the House of Representatives
they have held a bunch of these
different hearings that are of course
hearings meant only to Virtue signal and
meant only to not focus on issues
actually facing the country this
includes hearings about big Tech or the
weaponization of the FBI and yesterday
there was one such Hearing in which they
brought out
the Attorney General Merritt Garland to
answer questions Ted Cruz went to law
school and yet he seemed completely
confused about how the law Works in this
first clip and these hearings really
went wrong so quickly and we'll talk
about what these are really meant to
accomplish in a moment in this first
clip
Ted Cruz starts talking about leaks and
Merit Garland has to explain to him
remember Cruz is a lawyer no no no that
wasn't a leak that was a court filing
those are by definition made public take
a listen to this as you know the FBI
rated
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago home
and subsequent to that raid there have
been multiple leaks about what was
discovered there including a photograph
of documents that were discovered there
did you know about the leaks
rate the photograph was a filing in
court in response to a motion filed by
Mr trump it was not a leak so so you're
testified there haven't been leaks about
the the Trump raid investment I'm
responding to the point yeah Ted Cruz is
a lawyer doesn't he know how the law
Works he went to law school well it
doesn't matter because Ted Cruz is there
not as someone with some legal knowledge
as as rudimentary as it might be he's
there as a performer who is there to
attack Merit Garland and to further a
narrative that everything that has gone
on with the investigation into Donald
Trump has been some kind of politically
biased subterfuge or plan or whatever
the case may be then the subject comes
up of protesters outside the homes of
Supreme Court Justices and again
I'm guessing Ted Cruz knows this stuff
but Ted Cruz wants to pretend that it is
up to Merit Garland to enforce statutes
but it is actually up to law enforcement
on the scene and it is another one of
these just deranged performative moments
that Ted Cruz thinks make him look
really good how do you decide which
criminal statutes the the doj enforces
and which one it doesn't the United
States Marshals know that they have full
I recognize you want to give a separate
speech how do you decide which statute
you enforce and which ones you don't but
Marshall's on scene make that
determination in light of the priority
of the marshals do not make a
determination over whether to prosecute
you the attorney general make a
determination and you spent 20 years as
a judge and you're perfectly content
with justices being afraid for their
children's lives
and you this this is understand this is
merely a performance this is not to
investigate or learn a damn thing did
nothing to prosecute it let's shift to
it can I answer the question
refuse to answer I am answering her I'm
you're not I'm here to perform uh uh Mr
attorney general not for you to answer
my questions questions
how did you choose not to not to enforce
this statute the marshals on scene don't
make that decision do make the decision
of whether to make an arrest someone no
they don't if they make up if they make
it Marshalls do not have prosecution
they make an arrest
because our time is limited the time is
limited because Ted Cruz won't actually
let the witness answer the questions and
of course Ted Cruz is blending two
different things Ted Cruz is blending
what actions were and weren't taken at
the homes of Supreme Court Justices
which is completely up to law
enforcement and then as a separate
matter wants Merit Garland to discuss
indictments which are a separate issue
to actions taken or not taken at the
homes of law enforcement and again I
know Ted Cruz is like sort of dim but
he's not this dim and we all know Ted
Cruz knows that Ted Cruz then continues
in turning he's determined to turn this
hearing into a farce which he very
easily did and he starts talking about
what is effectively a conspiracy theory
for which there is no evidence arguing
that the Department of Justice leaked
about investigating Hunter Biden to
serve as a pretext to indict Trump by
being able to say see we're nonpartisan
if that's confusing to you if that
doesn't make sense to you it's because
it doesn't make sense
toward that end the Department of
Justice has leaked that doj is
investigating and intends to indict
Hunter Biden
the purpose of those leaks I believe was
to set the predicate for an indictment
of trump to say I love how even-handed
we are we're indicting abiding we're
indicting a trump
those leaks are not law
speculation
conspiracy theory unfounded no evidence
and also not a question to the witness
that is there
but remember these hearings in sum total
are performances that's what they are
meant to be
that's what they are meant to be
um another interesting moment was in
this exchange with Ted Cruz Merrick
Garland points out you know some of you
Republican senators are arguing that we
leak to help the left
now you're saying the leaks are to help
the right it's all incoherent but good
for merit Garland for pointing it out
the answer is the leaks are consistently
on one side of the aisle advancing one
political agenda so
it doesn't seem to me attorney general
that the FBI has a lot of confidence in
you because what they're doing clearly
is trying to distance themselves from
your decisions they're out there leaking
left right and center and saying it
wasn't us we didn't want to do it he
made us do it right what's that say
about their confidence in your
leadership so understand here and and
Garland will address it Cruz is arguing
you're making all these leaks to help
the left and Josh Hawley is saying the
leaks are coming out actually from
people who don't agree with you in order
to help the right no the previous
Senator said that they're leaking all in
favor of the left now you're saying
they're leaking all in favor I'm asking
you my question answer my question based
on this evidence don't dissemble
attorney general's expired answer my
question time is expired Senator cotton
yeah so uh Merrick Garland accurately
figuring out what the story is here and
it's a story that makes absolutely no no
uh sense whatsoever
um here is Merrick Garland then
debunking the Republican talking about
point about the FBI AI being used on
parents remember this was floating
around for a while oh they're sending
the FBI they're delic they're declaring
parents to be domestic terrorists if
they go to school board meetings and the
FBI is getting involved this was during
questioning from Senator John Kennedy
didn't you understand
by the way isn't isn't John Kennedy
insufferable the chilling effect that it
would have
two parents
when you issued your directive when you
directed your criminal divisions
and your counter terrorism divisions
to um
to investigate parents
who are angry
at school boards and administrators
during covet
Senator if you just give me a moment to
put the full context I did not do that I
did not issue any memorandum directing
the investigation of parents who are
concerned about their children quite to
the contrary the memorandum that you're
talking about says at the very beginning
of the memorandum that vigorous public
debate is protected by the First
Amendment and the kind of concerns that
you're talking about are as expressed by
parents are of course completely
protected the memorandum was aimed at
violence and threats of violence against
a whole host of school Personnel it was
not aimed at parents making complaints
to their school board
and if it came in the context of a whole
series of other kinds of violent threats
uh and violence against other public
officials yeah
um they don't care they're just getting
the question on the record you have to
understand you know Merrick Garland's
doing the best he can but all of these
questions are just performances and
these are sort of like auditions for
who's going to get on Hannity later on
last night another interesting moment
Senator Marsha Blackburn told Merritt
Garland she's going to send him a bunch
of Twitter you told me earlier
favor I am going to send you a letter
with a whole lot of Twitter and
different feeds to help you and that
she's going to help him by sending him
feeds investigation for the Hope Clinic
yeah Marcia Blackburn will help the
Department of Justice by sending Merrick
Garland a whole bunch of Twitter once a
viewer sent me a whole bunch of Alta
Vista I barely knew what to do with it
it was really crazy and then lastly here
is Republican senator from Arkansas Tom
Cotton
asking Merritt Garland
why did the doj not arrest protesters
outside the homes of Supreme Court
Justices listen to how that went
consider the efforts your department has
put into tracking down everyone who is
even on the capitol Greyhounds on
January 6 2021 yeah you've dedicated
million of man-hours millions to study
videotape to do forensic analysis of
computers and devices to go knock and
conduct interviews you can't allocate
just a few agents to look at people's
social media account to say they were
president outside of a Justice home
we're going to go arrest them and charge
them it's a black letter violation of
the law our priority is violence and
threats of violence and the protection
of the lies of the justices and that's
what we're doing yeah why did you spend
all this time
trying to figure out who all of the
criminals were on January 6th and yet
you're not out there trying to figure
out who stood holding a sign outside of
a supreme court Justice's house
why isn't that evidence of bias well no
we're focused on violence and threats of
violence so that's that's why we did
things the way we did them so listen
this probably accomplished its goals in
so far as it was meant to be a
performative display of repeating the
half and dim-witted concerns of the Fox
News audience quite frankly who only has
these concerns because the very same
people on these panels told them here's
what you need to be concerned about and
so it probably accomplished that goal
Merrick Garland did absolutely fine but
every single one of these hearings just
a complete and total face plant and
they're not going to stop because
they're then going to use these hearings
to justify we did things we accomplished
things even though these hearings
accomplish nothing
one of our sponsors today is Magic spoon
the breakfast cereal with the crunchy
sweet goodness you love but with high
quality ingredients less sugar and more
protein magic spoon has zero grams of
sugar it's packed with 13 to 14 grams of
protein and just four to five net carbs
so it's great if you're doing keto or
low carb or if just like me you're
trying to limit your sugar intake they
have many unique flavors so you'll never
get bored my personal favorite is maple
waffle but I grew up in New England so
maybe that's why Maple you know they
also have cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry muffin honey nut
cookies and cream cinnamon roll
sometimes there's really just no
substitute
for sitting down with a nice bowl of
cereal who doesn't love that when the
mood strikes go for something more
wholesome with plenty of protein and
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked simply go to
magicspoon.com Pacman you can create a
custom bundle and use the code Pacman
for five dollars off the link is down
below